[Musique]
merci notre direct avec nous je passe
toujours quelque chose dans cette
émission notre kit c'est de vous
détendre jusqu'à 21h tous les jours vous
mettez devant notre télé on kiffe tous
ensemble on apprend des choses on rigole
et grâce à vous sachez le
ça fait maintenant bas encore depuis le
début de la saison que tous les soirs
touche pas à mon poste et le premier
tokyo france merci merci les séries
merci beaucoup
ce soir encore ça va être la folie vous
les duels et 4h de jean luc lemoine ya
khalid combat qui va arriver plus tôt ce
soir ne peut louper pas et vous
continuez à voter pour le meilleur mini
sosie voilà de ce soir puisqu'ils vont
les découvrir après bien sûr ils vont
aller se coucher tout cela vous avez
vous coucher ou pas am inn et laura tu
vas te coucher
oh oui merci non merci génial alors oui
c'est vrai tu vas te coucher sorte tu
trouves ça qu'à leur toit ce soir moi
j'ai jamais dès ce mois ci le
anesthésiant main tendue est moi à tab
la tablette d'accord tête à nice où les
victoires à quatre pattes a fait la
vraie capucines à la belle salle caullet
et il a tout les n'aura à la plains
d'amoureux elle a dit voilà et excuse
moi de ma chérie je voulais dire qu'est
ce que tu veux qu est ce que tu veux me
dire et crétois de vraies questions
mais les départs d'accord va très bien
merci bien d'agathe on se calme matthieu
delormeau les allées découvrir votre
mini mathieu voulait nous dire si vous
trouvez qu'il ressemble on est très
mignon vraiment je vous le dis regardez
mathieu c'est parti on pouvait enlever
votre petit bandeau
travaux
alors
ou alors la ressemblance n'est pas folle
y en a qui sont beaucoup mieux voilà
qu'ils sont beaucoup plus ressemblants
par rapport par exemple isabelle où il
paraît en toi mon chien aussi voilà tu
étais vraiment s'en est beaucoup plus
beau que moi toi ils ont été sympas avec
moi aussi lui aussi il est beaucoup plus
beau munich serait un fils je voudrais
comme ça ah bah oui bahebeck qui
magnifie savate et compte encore
matthieu delormeau et muscler un secteur
mais autant de voir matthew pas capucine
agathon se calment vous êtes bavarde et
la mémoire de la attention attention à
tout ce qu'elle a dit attendez vous avez
vu isabelle isabelle morini bosc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je
chaput un arbre attention c'est parti au
pouvoir lever et découvrir votre mini
capus qui vous ressemble les normes
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez cap
et chine allait trop mignonne et j'ai
envie de faire un test de culture
générale entre vous et votre non mais
sans déconner à la question'' et reçoit
une interro surprise les deux attention
munich a pu et capucine qu'elle est
qu'elle est la capitale ne laisse pas
dit madrid
tu confirmes attention 2e 2e de +24 est
tout content radio cas tout seul à la
droite une petite ma chérie dernière
question derrière questionner donne moi
le résul le résultat 2 6 pouces 4 vite
vite mais n'arrive dix fils tu vas là
les collègues capucines cela dit il
écoute pas tout ce qu'elle te dis merci
wayne rooney ou alors attention
agathe vous allez découvrir votre mini à
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'elle commençait de la même
personne à ce que vous avez vu isabelle
morini bosc
ça peut être ça fait ch à tout le monde
non mais ça tout le monde s'il vous
plaît merci on se calme on respecte les
personnes inverse
jean michel maire michel qui est très
beau regarde c'est parti google goggles
heureusement ils ont été sympas gens
reconnaît qu'il aurait été sympa parce
que là il n'ya rien à voir
ce père qu'il n'a pas les mêmes
problèmes d'élocution quoi parle à tous
les deux vous allez devoir dire une
phrase difficile d'accord avec danseurs
un chasseur ça sont amers ces gens sont
à garder leur chien chat sur sa chance à
fond face à ces entretiens
ah oui je connais la phrase on y prend
le temps a filé la connais pas un
chasseur a sa chance sachez s'est assis
sur la phrase à chasseurs station la
mère avait vous c'est pas un chasseur
sachant chasser son chef à bombay
chasseurs
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est pas du tout ça la phrase a
dit bochy non non je jouais mon chien
est un monstre chasseurs navarre et
apparemment c'est vraiment pâtissent
toujours michel mr bim bim
thierry moment vous allez découvrir
votre minou titi regard des autres là il
a fait trop chaud
je
les normes alors d'abord et vous avez
une blague allure à côté tu sais comment
on attend déjà verre à cocktail à tout
le monde on n'entend rien un 4 4
on n'a rien entendu janvier thierry
pardon voilà je raconte à tout le moins
oui un type qui rentre dans un café ça
fait quoi
plouf merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ce qui arrivait
voilà j'ai ri vous avez fait qu est ce
que tu te trouvais ça drôle non pas des
mois hartmann
[Rires]
attention gilbert mesk général aussi
franchement vous avez été négatifs je
reconnais qu il aida était bien lotis
alors toiture monde ne pas grandir comme
ça quoi
[Applaudissements]
lui et vous n'avez jamais le nord-ouest
a donné ce qu'on va laisser isabelle
pour la fin d'ailleurs c'est vrai pour
le dommage est chaud et ben c'est bien
la première fois que ça vous arrive et
nora on a un problème c'est qu'on ne
vous voit pas parce que la même temps la
même taille que vous vous voit pas
derrière alors attention et nohra vous
pouvez voir votre minier elle est
magnifique
[Musique]
tu as trouvé lénora tu as trouvé dur
henry oui vrai tu aimes bien tu la
connais tu l'as bien quand même
ça va très bien et jean luc lemoine
vous allez découvrir votre niveau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment vous avez eu l'idée
non mais franchement il est bien loti
guerrières ne bouge pas mais hyper
mignon il fera son gouvernement dirait
qu'elle a vraiment sérieux et très beau
votre mini volley maxime infraction a
été très très bon
non vous allez tous ces débris sont
subis alors touché reconnaître c'est
vraiment la prod c'est ils ont vraiment
faire
[Applaudissements]
c'est possible on boit on voit vraiment
que ses mobiles
ouais merde isabelle gagné en asie oh
[ __ ] c'est sûr alors est-ce que ça
il
selva du doyenné des comestibles vous
êtes vous à contente d'être la mini sa
belle mort ibos oui c'est à vous l'aimez
bien quand même
oui un vrai progrès roxy en partance
qu'elle peut laisser tous les colliers
merci merci les séries alors voir tout
de suite pour qui vous allez voter
qu'est le meilleur pour mini f ration et
des millions alors attention moshiri
alors ah oui elle est belle et trois
provinces et agathe agathe
je vais demander à tous les enfants de
mia avec ont rappelé tous les autres
problèmes
l'hiver s'installe
données avec man les chalets parce que
venez venez vite merci déchiré à
jean-luc îles et îlots vraiment à gâter
avec moi mignacca 3 milliards gâtés avec
mon idole
bien sûr mes chéris mini mathieu garder
la mini et nollet chéri comme damien
alary évidemment chéri ya rappelle les
séries comme vous avez été formidables
ce soir bien entendu je ne peux pas vous
laisser partir sans rien attention et on
vous offre tous ces cadeaux regardez
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
voilà les séries ce pauvre
merci mais non merci merci desarnauts
merci d'être là on est en direct
merci les chaînes et
[Applaudissements]